weil ich wieder eurem organe und
willkommen zur allerersten folge in 2006
und willkommen zur allerersten folge in
2006 2006 2006 war wills wie starten wir
das wunderschöne jahr 2016 zu 2006 2006
über einen pc zwergstaat ich habe mein
leben stets das ist bis kanada mehr
videos machen damit wer von euch in
asien mehr schreibt meine kommentare auf
jeden fall habe ich hier fällt so ne
filz kissen filz stoff filz nadeln
stöcker ich habe noch nie gefühlt ich
weiß nicht wie es funktioniert ich werde
es einfach ausprobieren
denkt man kann tolle donuts und
haarspangen schmuck und sowas machen und
ich wäre einfach kein baby fan wenn ich
nicht machen würde versucht daraus eine
haarspange oder so zu machen man gucken
ob es mir gelegen wird
los geht's
schicke ich bin jetzt hier das basic ein
bisschen doof aus ich weiß aber nicht
mehr anders zu helfen und ihr seid ja
sehen was ich mache nicht nur meine
fresse man schauen was das klingt sehr
schön monat jetzt mal ganz ehrlich also
da brauchen wir nur ein bisschen drauf
machen egal und ich brauche eine
vielzahl
wie willst ich hätte mir ein youtube
tutorial vor angriffen sollen ende
waschen nehmen sie ihre schmutzigen
hände und streichen sie langsam von
vorne nach hinten über ihre kollegen
jetzt ein stück fehlt ja das wird ein
donut das wird ein absoluter fähig sie
das jetzt schon mal wie feldmann
du lernst wird die nares keiner kirche
widerhaken okay weil sie etwas zu
unterschied
wir geben nicht so schnell auf ok ich
versuche das jetzt hier noch eine weile
und fällt nicht leicht dann zurück
irgendwann später ja alle die jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon mal wenn ich ihn
auslachen
ich hab's nie gemacht
ich glaube ich aber immer krank wenn es
in der schule dran war oder ich hatte
immer den falschen kurs oder gipfels
maschine
damals diesen ton an haben brauchen wir
noch zuckerguss der so oben drauf kommt
die muss man noch zu schneiden und auf
den zuckerguss kann man noch so bunte
per leeze machen das dann soll man so
wellenförmig und kleiner 63
first try freute mich verarschen
die perle passt nicht durch nadelwälder
wenn ihr da eine kahle rein macht dann
erwartet man doch gibt es noch nicht da
bin ich jetzt ein bisschen zwar nicht
also da werde ich echt die passen nicht
durch
damit der harris und donner monster
jetzt wird's ernst wie nimmt man das
waren einfach so der welt aufgezeigt
dass man das
ordentlich hin sollen aber jetzt ein
bisschen wilder sind zu crazy
motherfuckers mache ich das jetzt ein
paar stich ist ehrlich wunderschön
entspannt und dann würde ich ihn so
spendeten
aber ich zeige ich dir wie das aussieht
also bis dann